bonsoir de l'ase écrit merci beaucoup
d'être avec nous en direct sur rt france
cette charte aux emmanuel macron l'a
salué comme étant un engagement net
clair et précis en faveur de la
république c'est aussi votre avis c'est
un texte qui va être efficace compte
pour lutter contre le séparatisme
je ne pense pas dès lors le séparatisme
je n'aime pas du tout lors d'une
rencontre avec madame à la ministre de
l'intérieur on y avait dit que le mois
séparatistes franchement de déranger il
avait pris l'engagement que ça soit
supprimée il a été supprimé
aujourd'hui les journalistes et des
hommes politiques et pas de séparatisme
il ya le renforcement si vous voulez de
la laïcité mais séparatisme les
musulmans n'ont jamais demandé de l'état
le deuxième fois je suis surpris que
j'entendais jours à l'essai compris vous
dire que 5 de chardy le conseil national
du sida
amd présenté au président qu'il a été
satisfait et comme tout le monde était
d'accord je suis désolé de ce qui a été
rapporté par tous les correspondants qui
était sur place en c'est pas nous qui
ont été alors il ya peut-être là il n'y
a peut-être pas de manger et vous allez
nous expliquer mais voilà je tenais à
moundir c'est ce qui a été trouvé tes
côtés de dire ce qui fait les
journalistes qui étaient sur place il ya
cinq fédérations qui se sont rendus sur
beat generation à l'elysée les trois ans
n'était pas présent et nous passer des
sept chars
donc il n'y a pas unanimité d'ailleurs
hier lorsqu'elle a visé la
visioconférence entre la fédération il
ya des fédérations qui ont dit
clairement qu'ils signeraient pas
charger pardonnez-moi pardonnez moi je
retiens excusez moi je tiens à vous
couper parce que la question c'était
voilà emmanuel macron qu'ils sont
félicités sa lettre n 2 mai prochaine
question trois fédérations qui n'ont pas
de tous signé le texte donc là je vous
parlait d' emmanuel macron qu'ils sont
satisfaisants et je ne parlais pas de
tout le monde qu'on soit bien clair
voilà merci
je pense que ce présent la république
avant de se féliciter
il faut qu'il déclare clairement qui a
pas unanimité sur ce texte parce que
campe avec une charge sur les îles et
que les images sont absents des débats
je passe sacha dans la chance
effectivement c'était ma question
suivante trois fédérations dans
l'association foi et pratique un plutôt
présenté comme ultra rigoriste n'ont pas
signé ce texte c'est monsieur moussaoui
un du csm d'ailleurs qu'il a dit aux
journalistes sur place parlant de
quelques petites nuances lui il a parlé
de petites nuances à monsieur moussaoui
du cfcm dont vous faites partie
quelles sont ces nuances peut-être que
vous n'avez pas la même lecture ce ne
sont pas des petites nuances il ya des
grands désaccords selon vous je pense
pas des petites nuances parce que c'est
avec des petites des ans se serait
présenté pour et d'essayer expliqué il
ya une des cinq ans beaucoup de sujets
et par conséquent les trois fédérations
n'ont pas signé moi je fais partie de la
fédération mosquée de paris lorsqu'elle
paraît pas la signer mais maintenant les
autres fédérations qui l'ont pas signé
elles sont entièrement libres maintenant
elles sont des raisons c'est intéressant
mais il est vrai que dans cette charte
c'est dur vu à ce que tout ce qu'on a
signés et tous cas été dans l'achat
existe déjà par le passé et je pense que
ça ne servait à rien certains artistes
je prends par exemple la lca prêt simple
jusqu'à l'égalité en vain je ne sais pas
les jambes et les musulmans est ce ce
problème là existent en france qu'après
maintes reprises à la ministre chargée
de l'égalité
donc ce que l'égalité n'existe pas c'est
pas le fait des musulmans pas du tout et
rien d'autre un autre point aussi je
vois qu'à l'assemblée nationale ils sont
pas du tout d'accord sur ce sujet là moi
je dis que chaque camp savoir quand ça
danse on a des images les premiers
intéressés
ça va être les imams c'est la base qui
doit décider ce n'est pas le sommet
alors effectivement vous faites bien de
parler des imams parce que c'est l'un
des points clés de cette charte la
création d'un conseil national des imams
qui sera chargé je cite un de labelliser
les imams exerçant en france
je cite encore la charte et signataires
doivent rejeter clairement toute
ingérence de l'étranger dans la gestion
de leur mosquée et la mission de leurs
imams la mission de leur imam est ce que
ce n'est pas un petit peu paradoxal
quand on sait que voilà de nombreuses
fédérations sont justement financé par
les pays étrangers il n'y a pas un
confit d'intérêt
oui je suis avec vous il y a trois pays
qui ont des imams en france la jeune et
la joke et le maroc
mais c'est zimbra ils sont venus là
désaccord signale que l'on doit français
assure qu' il manque et d'image
maintenant le présent à public souhaite
qu'ils puissent plus hardiment à partir
de 2023
ça c'est son choix est libre mais ce
sont des humains qui sont venus soit à
désaccord maintenant il brille et livia
des pays qui financent sens qu'il paris
les e-marchands plis par l'algérie la
turquie qui va rentrer chez eux s'ils y
aura plus de financement au niveau des
images passées depuis l'étranger
donc comment fait-on ça veut dire que
cette charte va de toute manière avoir
du mal finalement être appliqué non dans
le concret oui devant être appliquée
parce que je vous dis dans un chat au
départ à gardant sa chat existait déjà
il existe le problème principal pour
nous la plupart des musulmans que j'ai
vu parce qu'on a pu consulter la base
n'a pas consulté les immeubles du
terrain le problème hier c'est le
respect
nous respectons les malheurs à nous qu'à
chaque fois des nombreux procès ont été
la réussite et oui la laïcité et toute
la laïcité
la laïcité c'est la non ingérence dans
les affaires de cul les parcelles du
culte musulman mohammed moussaoui
président du cfcm
sur le perron daniël de l'elysée salue
l'unité retrouvée au sein du conseil
français du culte musulman alors ça veut
dire quoi que il faut lui demander à lui
moi je sais qu'il n'y a pas d'unité a
pas d'unité brand elle a voulu essayer
si vous voulez de rassurer mais il n'y a
pas d'unité et fait un truc l'air il
faut pas quand même raconté n'importe
quoi
je ne faut pas mentir aux gens que je
connais c'est quelqu'un de près je pense
pas qu'il vaut mais il essaie d'arrondir
les angles
voilà c'est tout parce que vieillir et
un débat fédération il y en avait qui
n'avaient pas attendre et 5 d'éprouver
ce matin à l'elysée aux trois
fédérations importantes étaient à
présent clairement à des écrits il y
avait une pression de l'exécutif pour
que les fédérations signe ses textes
c'est pas moi qui la vente ans et si
certains ne sont pas sept chats
nous en tirerons les conséquences avait
avertit emmanuel macron est ce que c'est
une forme de pression vous avez
peut-être ressenti pour signer ce texte
je sais ça fait 25 ans que dans le culte
je n'ai jamais vu une des pressions
exercées sur l'islam et les musulmans
il peut y avoir des débats le président
république à la il a un agenda il a un
calendrier il veut aller vite mais je
pense c'est pas à l'envi qu'empirer le
problème il faut pas confondre vitesse
et précipitation
merci beaucoup avait la dcri d'avoir été
avec nous délégué général du cfcm
d'avoir été en direct assure rt france